what's going on everybody welcome back
to another video today I'm going to tell
you my favorite ways to use chat GPT for
data analysis and then we're going to
actually analyze some data
[Music]
now chat gbt has taken the World by
storm it is Pretty stinking impressive
I've been using myself and I've been
pretty Blown Away with some of the
results if you have not tried it yet I
highly recommend trying it yourself what
we're going to be doing today is I'm
going to walk you through four of the
top things that I've been using chat GPT
for for actual data analysis and then
we're going to take a small data set and
we're just going to ask it some
questions and we're going to prompt it
to do a few things and see how it
responds I'm going to tell you right at
the beginning it's pretty incredible and
this is just chat gbt 3.5 in future
variations in future iterations when
they make improvements I probably will
be making more videos on a lot of the
new functionalities in the enhanced
abilities that chat GPT has so let's
take a look at my favorite ways that
I've been using chat GPT as a data
analyst all right so I've got my
computer in front of me if you have not
seen this before if you know what this
is this is the interface for using chat
GPT so on this left hand side we have
these discussions and these are previous
ones that I've been doing just testing
things out I've gotten rid of of a lot
of them because I've done this a lot and
this is the actual interface now this is
what it shows when it's just prompting
you hey here's some ideas that you can
do and then down here is where you're
going to actually write what you're
doing so we're going to be feeding chat
gbt something called a prompt basically
telling it or asking it to do something
so one of the first use cases for Chachi
BT is that it can explain code really
well so I'm going to ask it to explain
some python code and we'll see what it
says so let's go ahead and say explain
this python code I'm going to come right
up here this is just my Jupiter
notebooks I'm literally just going to
take this this is from a project that I
created just a unit of measurement
converter
and I haven't given it any information
besides that it's literally just the
code and it's going to have to take the
string and the code that I've actually
written and try to explain it to me so
all we're going to do is we're going to
click enter
and right now I'm working with the
completely free version so everything
that's about to generate is based off
the free version I'm not paying for any
of this
um I don't really believe in paying but
let's actually take a look at what it's
explaining so it's I'm not going to read
all of it but it says this code is a
simple unit converter converting between
inches feet and yards it says the user
is prompted to enter the unit of
measurement to convert and the code
converts the user's input it says the
code uses lower function to convert the
user's input to lowercase so the inputs
are case insensitive and that's 100
right if we go back to the code is
literally asking the user to input some
unit of measurement what they want to
convert it to and then this logic just
converts it for it it's fairly simple
may be a lot of code if you don't know
python but it's actually fairly simple
and Chad gbt does an extraordinary job
just explaining it really in layman
terms now I've been using chat EBT to
explain codes to me because some people
are sending me code and I just don't
fully understand it a hundred percent
I'm like okay I get the gist of it but
when I ask it to explain that sometimes
it'll go in even more detail and it's
really really useful especially if
you're first starting out and you're not
fully understanding some code or a
script that you're getting or trying to
write now that's just python code you
could use it for SQL or for R for any
other programming language or even
something like a Excel function it
really could be whatever you want
explained you just put it in here and
it'll explain it to you now the next
thing that I can do is actually generate
code so I'm going to ask it to generate
some python code as well as some SQL
code and we'll see what it gives us I'm
going to come right down here to the
prompt and I'm going to say write a
python script to scrape data oops data
from Twitter
without my IP address
being blocked and let's see what it
comes up with
so the generating code is actually
really amazing because oftentimes it'll
give you somewhat boilerplate options or
boilerplate responses but it also gives
some context here because what it's
explaining right now is that you really
shouldn't do that or you know here's
some reasons why you may not want to do
this and now it's going to actually
generate the text now it even has up
here a copy codes you can just come in
here copy this code and you're good to
go right here you can see your consumer
key your consumer secret this is using
the Twitter API so it's saying you need
to use the Twitter API but I could say
not using the Twitter API and it would
generate an entire other response
without using the Twitter API so it's
pretty incredible
and it's still going
um there's a lot of information and if
you don't use any apis if you're not
used to using um things like that if you
don't know python at all
um this is fairly straightforward it's
fairly simple
um this isn't I'm going to scroll up
real quickly this isn't anything like
super Advanced this is something that I
could probably Google and get pretty
quickly but it's generating it based off
of my requests that I don't want my IP
address to be blocked
um so it's giving me some options to
actually do that which I think is just
fantastic that's really really
impressive and it even explains it at
the bottom how it helps you avoid this
IP address being blocked from Twitter so
again just pretty impressive stuff but
let's go ahead and try it with SQL code
so we're going to come down here and say
write a MySQL stored procedure
that automatically
Imports data from a CSV at a specific
path
and let's see how we write this now
I've worked a lot with this stuff with
data collection importing data
automatically when a CSV gets dropped
into a file you want to automatically
take that data into the database super
super common
um so let's see how it writes this now I
just got a network error basically chat
gbt is overwhelmed and it couldn't
finish my response this is happening a
lot with chat gbt I just want to kind of
explain this they now have a paid
version that you can pay for it's like
20 bucks a month or the more advanced
version which is 42 a month this won't
happen if you pay for it
um but if you don't which most people
don't want to do you're going to
encounter these types of Errors so I'm
just going to do is I'm going to refresh
it even says we're experiencing
exceptionally high demand that's
completely true but
I don't want to pay for it so I'm going
to show you and hopefully it'll generate
the entire thing without me having to
pay for this because I really don't want
to let's see what it's writing so it's
creating the stored procedure
and it's using this import CSV it's
giving our file path and telling it to
put it in this um in this table right
here and so it's literally looking for a
CSV and then it's going to actually
write the code to load that CSV so
that's what it's doing right here and
you could use this you know you have to
have certain settings in my SQL don't
just copy this and paste it you have to
input some information you have to have
certain settings set up in my SQL as
well but then it just kind of explains
it a little bit for you it's pretty
great I've used some variation of this
and each time I run this it gives me a
different version sometimes it's more
Dynamic sometimes it's more hard-coded
so actually knowing this skill when it's
generating code actually knowing SQL is
really important I wanted to warn some
people out there because a lot of people
are like okay you know I'm just learning
SQL I should just use this to learn SQL
and I'm like I don't think that's a good
idea because if you do not know this
code already and it tells you to do
something you may get a worse option or
a not perfect option and you need to
know it so just looking at this this is
pretty good this is pretty similar to
something I've worked with but in
previous versions it's given me
different options that I didn't like as
much so be careful with this one when
it's actually generating the code
oftentimes you'll need to tweak it or
change it I have found that chat gbt is
pretty good but sometimes it just gets
things wrong or it just gives me bad
options and I'm like this is not good
code or it's not perfect code and I have
to tweak it quite a bit to get it to
what I want it to do now the next thing
that I really like chat gbt for is
writing comments for my code so let's
take this for example let's say I have
this code I'm going to say
can you please I like to be polite can
you please write
comments or this SQL code I'm just going
to paste it in there and I'm going to
ask it to write comments for it if you
haven't written any code you may not
know what that means but comments are
just you know added information for
somebody if they're coming in and
looking at your code or for you in six
months to come back and look at your
code you know exactly what it's doing so
it's going to describe every part of
this code for you which can save you a
ton of time if you're commenting your
own code that can take a while and you
can just go in here and add a little bit
more information if you want to but this
is like a fantastic starting place for
comments and code which
I personally sometimes forget
um and so I've been using this for even
more complex code like this is fairly
simple code to comment I've given it
even more complex code it's done a
pretty good job there are times where it
gets it kind of wrong but this is pretty
impressive for actually generating
comments for code it's saying exactly
what each step is doing the next use
case that I've been using chat gbt for
is for creating data dictionaries now if
you don't know what a data dictionary is
it's basically a table or something that
describes what data is in your data set
whether it's in a CSV or a SQL server or
wherever wherever that data sits it's
good to have that data dictionary to
know exactly what data you have so I'm
going to say
can you give me a data dictionary
or this data set now I'm just going to
paste this in here I just copy this from
an Excel so that's all I did and I'm
going to hit enter now it's starting to
generate this it's going to actually
give me a table so it's creating this
table of the column name that's in there
the type of data that is in there and
then an actual description of it now I
haven't given it any previous
information it's doing this purely based
off of context so it's taking this name
State and saying okay this description
must be the state name it's doing a
total population so that must be the
total population then it's even taking
in things like comparison operators and
it's saying these rates dot age is
saying a rate for age less than 18. now
this is fairly fairly simple I'm not
saying it's giving you anything Advanced
it's not giving you a ton of information
beyond what it's reading in in the
column name as well as reading in in the
data so if you give it a more complex
data set sometimes it even takes the
data that's in there and it says okay
these are state name but they're labeled
something different it's labeled just
one two three for the column name so
then it will tell you this one two three
column is state name so it even takes
that into consideration it's pretty wild
I mean it is really really impressive
now again I'm just giving you like one
or two examples of each of these
otherwise this video would be like an
hour long but the next thing that I've
been using chat gbt for is optimizing my
code now let's go right over here this
is an actual SQL query that I have
written I'm going to copy this it's just
doing uh what I would consider fairly
let's take a look at it a fairly simple
um window function as a sub query and
that's using a case statement to kind of
use that information let's see how it
would optimize this code
can you please optimize this my SQL code
and I'm going to give it the code now
what it's going to do is literally take
it in and rewrite it to properly run it
faster to actually optimize that code
now if you don't know what query
optimization is it's basically where
you're either changing a query or you're
changing the database to run faster so
what it's actually doing here is
creating an index this is a way that you
can optimize code although for this code
that's not exactly what I was wanting I
wanted it to optimize the query and not
create an index which does speed it up
that is a fact but I'm going to now say
I'm just going to say can you optimize
this in just the query itself
so it's going to remember the previous
thing that I asked it to do and now it's
going to understand by context what I'm
asking it because I don't have to
actually input my query again it's going
to know let's see exactly what happens
so I've tried this twice and it gave me
different answers each time last time it
gave me what I hope it's going to give
me now that time it gave me an index
which it didn't give me before so it
gives you different things it's just
really really fascinating how this works
now what it's giving me right here is
the actual output that I was hoping it'd
give you although this is a learning
opportunity that's just how chat GPT
works this right here is what I thought
it would give you instead of the index
but what it did here is instead of in
this part of the code having this select
everything what it is now doing is just
selecting the actual columns that we
need so now it's just selecting employee
ID department and salary instead of all
of the columns as well as this window
function right here now it's going to
even tell you why it does that or how it
does that so by using a sub query to
only retrieve the columns that are
actually needed in the final result you
reduce the amount of data that is needed
to be processed which speeds up the
query so those are all ways that I've
been using chat gbt it's been pretty
amazing I will give the disclaimer
though that not every time do I get
great results there are often times
where I have to reword things or I have
to ask it to generate another response
and that happens a lot but when I
actually do get what I'm looking for
it's pretty impressive like I usually
I'm like wow how did it do that it's
pretty cool now what I want to do is
just take a small data set and do some
data analysis kind of show you some of
the things that it can do some of the
ways that I would use it I'm just going
to pull a data set from kaggle and use
that keep it pretty simple not use any
real data with any information I
shouldn't be putting into chat gbt on it
so let's go down here and in this Excel
file and we'll be using this one later
in this Excel file I have this data set
right here now this is going to run
really slowly because this is a lot of
data but but I'm just and I say a lot of
data it's only 30 rows but Chachi BT
does not take in this data well
so let's get rid of this and all I'm
going to say is you are a data analyst
so I'm giving it some context that's who
you are that's what you do here's what I
want you to do can you please give
me some insights
and recommendations on this data set and
I'm going to input this data in here now
when I hit enter it's going to analyze
this really quickly now if you ask it to
do other things which we're going to do
in just a little bit it may take quite a
while so I want to give it a second to
actually write everything basically what
it's saying is to actually provide
insights and recommendations we want to
take some initial steps and these are
some pretty common things that you'll
want to do with data like data cleaning
exploratory data analysis product
analysis geographical analysis and time
series analysis so let's take a look at
this data really quickly
we do have a product
we do have an order ID the actual
product how many we have the price the
order date and where it was purchased
from
so what it can say based off of just
giving it the data set randomly it says
you can offer discounts or promotions on
the least frequently ordered products to
increase their sales now what we could
do is literally take this and say
can you tell us
more about this
and I'm just going to ask it to explain
it a little more so what it told us is
you can offer discounts and here's why
you'd want to do it because you'll
attract more customers and it even tells
us how to identify these products and
I'm going to ask it can you identify
these products for us and I'll say and
output
the SQL code as well so if we go back up
so it's generating the code it says to
identify the least frequently ordered
products you can use the following SQL
code it literally writes the code out
for you with the actual column names
that it says you should be using that's
the part that always kind of like
just think is really impressive because
this kind of code is actually
um fairly simple fairly generalized but
it makes it not so generalized because
it's actually using your data that's the
part that always like blows my mind I'm
like
that's just really impressive that's
using your actual column names or your
actual code or generating your code
using your common names that is the part
that's usually pretty impressive to me
so all this is doing and it even says
we're using the product count so we're
using an aggregate function in the
orders table and counts the numbers of
times each product appears and selects
the top 10 least frequently ordered
products again pretty simple but you
know we've asked it to do a lot of
contextual things take a look at this
data set tell us how to offer discounts
and actually write the code to identify
what we should be offering discounts on
it's pretty pretty cool now let's say we
didn't want to use SQL because that's
we're using right now I'm going to say
Can you take
our data set and put it into a pandas
data frame in Python so I'm going to see
if it remembers sometimes it does
sometimes it doesn't looks like this
time it does depending on how far back
the conversation is or if it remembers
what our data set is sometimes it
remembers sometimes it doesn't this
times it looks like it is working
now
what it's actually doing is creating
each row of that data and inputting it
as data now sometimes this is going to
error out it takes too much processing
power and we have like 30 rows it's only
on Row three so I'm going to let this
run for a little bit we'll see if it
actually works so it's looking like it
aired out it just stopped it just
stopped this is the uh I would say
somewhat downfall of the chat GPT right
now is that the servers are just
overloaded there's like millions and
millions of people trying to use it at
this very moment so oftentimes when it's
using these large data sets it just
doesn't work in the future I think there
will be add-ons to things like Excel and
my SQL and all these different things
where it'll be integrated with it and
process it much faster but now it
doesn't so we're just going to refresh
and keep going from here and we're just
going to go right back up here and this
is our previous data sets and we'll
scroll all the way to the bottom so it
saved our conversation thank goodness
um but it just you know it just blanked
out and luckily it saved us that was a
good thing now because I refreshed it
let's see if it still remembers um again
we're trying to analyze data we're
trying to get some information out of
here but you know these things are
happening so I'm just kind of going with
the flow so what I'm going to say is
what products
in our data set
made us the most profit
let's see if it remembers
so now it's going to say to identify
these products you need to calculate the
total revenue so this part is really
cool because it's going to kind of based
off of our prompt basis based off of us
saying we want profit it's going to say
we need to calculate the profit first to
determine the profit so it's going to
write it's using pandas but we can ask
it to write this in my sequel but it's
going to take it and say okay take the
quantity ordered times the price of each
one and this is our like potential
profit and it's even giving us comments
I mean it's really going above and
beyond I mean if you were to integrate
this in something like python or you
know any other thing this could be a
fantastic tool but this is pretty great
um this looks like pretty standard code
it's even grouping it and giving us the
sum so if we ran this if we took this
and put it in Python and we had our data
set in there then it would probably give
us pretty close to the right answer now
I'm going to ask it to write this in
MySQL as well so I'm going to say can
you write this in my SQL
and there we go so it wrote it in my
sequel as well and this looks pretty
simple and very straightforward it looks
correct to me now one thing I want to
say is we're analyzing this data we're
kind of prompting it I'm just giving
some examples right we're not going to
do like a full analysis I could do that
in a whole another video but
um what we're doing is just I'm giving
examples of how you can actually ask it
to analyze this data for you so what
we're going to do next is we're going to
ask it to categorize some information
for us so I'm going to say
can you categorize let me say the
products that made us a lot of money
versus a little bit of money
in my Sequel and do my SQL so we're
asking it now to categorize this data
for us if it made us a lot of money
we're going to want it to say it made us
a lot of money if it's a little money we
want to tell us it made us a little bit
of money let's see how it does this and
again this is all pretty you know
generalized questions kind of open-ended
questions we're going to see how it
actually interprets that open-ended
question
um
and so it's literally writing a case
statement saying it's a if it's over a
thousand it's a lot of money if it's
less than 500 it's a little bit of money
so this um this is something that you
know it's really interesting you know
this is not something that I'd ever
write in like a real SQL query
um because is leaving that 500 to a
thousand somewhere in there and it's
saying it's somewhere in between
um I would never actually do this in
real code but that's how it's
interpreting it and writing it so this
would be a mistake to me this is just
like a small thing that I would go back
and change and you know customize
um but we could give it more specific
prompts you could say if they made us a
profit of more than a thousand dollars
give it this if it was less profit then
this number give it less so we could
even give it more specific and it would
do it now if you remember from our Excel
right here we have this
column and what we want to do is break
it out by the street the city and the
state as well as zip code so I'm going
to ask it to do that
because this is something that I've
actually done a ton in SQL python in any
programming language is breaking it out
so you can group on it and and you know
clean up that data better because in its
current state it's not very usable so
I'm going to say
can you break out the last column
into Street
City
State and zip code columns we'll say in
MySQL now you can do the exact same
thing for python or whatever but let's
see how it writes this now
I post this on Instagram the other day
and before it was using substring index
let's see if that's how it does it again
and it looks like it is and this is
almost exactly how I would write this so
this one really impressed me because I'm
like writing this code to test this
video or like write make this video this
would really impressed me because
you know substring index using substring
and locates like this is you know it's
not super straightforward it's not super
easy but it doesn't
um just very very impressive in my
opinion very impressive how it's able to
write this and this code if I'm just
glancing at this this code looks correct
like I could run this and it would take
that column break it out into those four
columns for us now what we would want to
do because this is just in a select
statement but I could literally and
let's try it I could literally just tell
it can you create
new columns for each of those
so again I'm being vague each of those
I'm just kind of tested a little bit
while we're in this video so you can see
how impressive this is so now it's going
to create a new column City State Street
and zip code and then it's going to tell
us how we can do that
um I don't know it's just really really
cool
and uh now it's literally writing the
code to use that substring index which
we generated up here which look correct
and now it's telling us in these um you
know update statements how to actually
apply that to those columns that we
created with this code all you have to
do is copy and paste this again
it's blowing me away a little bit every
time I run it it's just kind of like how
does that work like on the back end what
code are they writing uh or what code
are they using to to generate this it's
just really impressive now you can ask
it to convert it to a different
programming language or whatever you
want and it would do it
um but what we're going to do now is do
something a little bit different I'm
going to ask it and I'm gonna actually I
forgot to create this beforehand I'm
just going to say first underscore name
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
give it all types of different inputs so
I'm going to say sam and then I'm going
to do
um Cal Lee and then I'm going to do
josh123 so I'm going to take this I'm
going to ask it to clean this data for
us just sounds like a small example
can you clean this new data set
and I'm going to give it to it just see
what it does if I need to be more
specific I will but let's see how it
takes in that data and standardize it
even says right here
we're going to use upper to standardize
the text and to remove numbers from the
characters you can use regex replace
which is 100 accurate that's probably
what I would do if I had a large data
set with all data like this in there I
would be using those things to clean
this up so this code right here is going
to take regex replace and replace all
those uh numbers
and just keep the letters basically is
actually what that's doing
um and that's going to put it all upper
so I don't want an upper case I'm going
to say I don't want it in uppercase I
want proper case could you please write
that code as well
and I'm going to see what it does I hope
it makes it into more proper case
because I don't like using it in
uppercase just not always what I like
visually seeing
let's see what it does so it's basically
going to use init cap and make it a more
proper case instead of doing it all on
upper or lower or something like that
and now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to say can you put that cleaned
data in a table for me
and it's going to actually generate this
and create a table for you to copy and
paste
um
and it's actually creating the table
that's not what I wanted if I'm being
honest I wanted it to create just a list
for me to copy and paste so I'm going to
say while it's generating it I'm going
to say
can you put this in a list so I can copy
and paste this
into Excel
so let's see if it does better this time
because I didn't want it to create the
table in SQL but that's the context that
I was understanding and now it's doing
it in Python again not exactly what I
wanted but it's doing something right
it's definitely working hard to try to
understand what I'm trying to tell it I
just want it to literally give me like
something I can copy and paste and it's
not doing that exactly I could just take
this if I wanted to and break it out but
it's not doing exactly what I wanted
although that happens with chat gbt the
very last thing I'm going to do and I'm
just going to go back here is I have the
second data set and it's a lot of data
so I'm just going to take like the first
two columns
and what I'm going to do is just ask it
to basically explain what this data set
is I'm just going to say can you please
explain
what is in this data set
now I'm being specifically vague for a
reason because you can be much more
specific you can say explain to me what
these columns are and how they correlate
to each other you can explain ask it to
explain almost anything
but it's basically going to give us some
context some overview of what kind of
data is in here much like a data
dictionary would
it's kind of doing the same thing now
this is going to take a long time so
there's a lot of columns there's like
like 30 or 40. but it's doing its thing
it's going to keep going until it
explains all of them unless it errors
out because it's just the system's
overwhelmed but while this is running
these are some ways that you can
actually analyze data I'm just giving
you a lot of examples because I want you
to go and test this out it's I don't
know there's no other word to use other
than just
it's really impressive
um I'll have an entire other video that
I'm going to be making on this which I'm
basically going to be talking about how
it'll help with data analysis
um the data analyst job market how it'll
impact it in the future and some
predictions that I have about its
capabilities and things like that
there's just a lot going on in this
world
um Google's about to come out I'm just
kind of giving some filler for my next
video on this but Google's coming out
with its own version I believe it's
called Sparrow it's using their Lambda
model that they've built and I'm super
excited for that one so I probably will
do some comparisons between those as
well this type of
technology is just it's gonna change
things I don't know how exactly I have
some predictions I have some
um you know information that I'll be
providing this is going to change things
this is just incredible and it can
analyze data like this on these small
data sets but when it's Incorporated in
things like Azure like with Microsoft
which is you know doing some big things
if it's Incorporated with Azure and it
can analyze these huge massive data sets
a lot faster
a lot of things could change so in this
video I kind of showed you a lot of my
favorite things that I've been using
Chachi BT for I've showed you some of
the functionalities as well and then we
even analyzed some data just kind of
poking around and asking it questions
and seeing how it interpreted those
questions as well as asking it to write
it in Python and SQL so you know I just
gave you a few different variations and
flavors it wasn't like a full analysis
this is just like an example in another
video I might take an entire real data
set and see if I can get chat EBT to
analyze it well
um but not in this video so I hope that
this is helpful and I hope that this was
exciting for you this stuff is super
super exciting to me I find it just
incredibly interesting and I think it's
just really impressive so go try it out
yourself go see if you like it I will be
making more videos on stuff like this
because I personally think it's just
incredible so with that being said thank
you for watching this video I hope you
learned something I hope this piqued
your curiosity be sure to like And
subscribe and I'll see you in the next
video
foreign
[Music]